the 10% myth is a funny one because it
doesn't come from an identifiable neuro
scientific discovery the earliest
mention of the idea that you only use
10% of your brain comes from the
motivational speaker and writer Dale
Carnegie and how to win friends and
influence people he said that actually
Lowell Thomas said it in the preface and
before that the only statement that
resembles that is again as I mentioned
before this pioneer of psychology and as
it turns out neuroscience William James
he told audiences that we only meet a
fraction of our full potential and I
think that statement is true because
it's certainly the case for instance
that IQ scores have gone up a few points
per decade in modern times which
suggests that there's some influence in
the environment on what we can become so
clearly we're not in that sense we may
be still exploring our full potential
but the 10% idea is literally not true
if you if you damage any part of the
brain you can if any part of the brain
is damaged it can lead to deficits of
function for instance if I damage if a
person experiences damage to the
cerebellum which guides smooth movements
then people are unable to move smoothly
unable to learn new things like a dance
step or a tennis stroke and you can come
up with similar kinds of observations
for all parts of the brain so you really
need the whole thing you need a 100
percent of your brain if any part of
your brain went missing in action you
would notice and you'd be sorry well
depending actually depending on the part
of the brain you might not be sorry
a really common belief about the brain
that you hear at parties is the idea
that drinking alcohol kills brain cells
you know you people make light of this
all the time the truth is that alcohol
can damage the brain but that it's
highly unlikely to kill brain cells when
people look at the brains of alcoholics
post mortem it takes decades of drinking
before a loss of brain cells becomes
apparent okay so and in fact loss of
brain cells when it does eventually
happen it's associated with a profound
loss of memory a thing called Korsakoff
syndrome and that happens after decades
of drinking now that having been said
alcohol does cause damage to the brain
so one thing that has been observed is
that heavy drinking for years does lead
to shrinkage of the brain and that is
probably the source of the idea that
alcohol kills brain cells that you can
observe shrinkage of the brain now let's
put these two together alcohol causes
shrinkage of the brain but the cells
don't diminish a number so what that
suggests is there's something about each
individual cell that's shrinking and
what's believed is that that the trees
the dendritic trees that neurons have
may retract a little bit and then they
are constantly growing and shrinking and
so what's believed is that perhaps they
retract a little bit and the practical
implication of this is that if you stop
drinking then they perhaps will grow
back okay so that's the practical
implication and so even though the the
myth even though the idea is a myth it's
still important to remember that
drinking alcohol is not a good thing for
your brain when you do it for many years
at a time I have more that I forgot to
give so can I throw that in okay sorry
about that okay the other side of the
coin is that moderate amounts of alcohol
are not harmful and in some cases can
even be helpful and there's a very
specific case which is red wine it turns
out that moderate amounts of red wine
seem to have some kind of protective
effect on brain function especially as
you are getting older and it's not known
exactly why but there's a general
principle which is that things that are
good for your heart and your
cardiovascular system are also good for
your brain and so there are health
benefits that been demonstrated of red
wine some of which are mediated through
the compound resveratrol and what's been
observed is that up
- three glasses of red wine per day for
men and up to two glasses for women is
either neutral or slightly beneficial
for brain function and that adds up to a
bottle for a couple per day so that's
you know easy to remember
all drugs exert their effects by acting
on some kind of receptor in the brain
and in some cases in many cases that
receptor is identified so for instance
to pick an example cocaine and
methamphetamine act upon a drug whose
job at it to pick an example cocaine and
methamphetamine act upon a molecule
whose job it is to suck up dopamine back
into cells after it's been released and
so those are blockers of dopamine
reuptake another example is LSD which
acts upon very specific receptors for
the neurotransmitter serotonin so all
these act upon different receptors to
cause their effects to cause
hallucinations or intoxication or
feelings of confidence or what-have-you
and a consequence of that is that they
are addictive to differing degrees so
for instance alcohol is addictive
nicotine in cigarettes is addictive
cocaine and meth methamphetamine are
highly addictive and so those tend to
lead to dependencies and bad effects
that you feel for many years and you get
trapped and using those things other
drugs seem to not have much addictive
potential and you mentioned LSD LSD is
not addictive so far as anyone can tell
and does not seem to lead to long-term
harmful effects all these drugs act on
different things I mean they're not
clean laboratory designed experiments
that we can perform on our brains they
tend to have lots and lots of different
effects I think that if alcohol were to
appear as a new drug today I think it
would be basically banned immediately
because of all the drugs that are
available it's this nasty solvent that
can kill cells that can cause dendrites
to shrink that can lead to us to be
unable to operate machinery safely and
can cause people to you know beat up
their loves one loved ones and spouses I
mean it's a fairly serious drug but it's
been around the longest and so through
familiarity we think it's okay you know
red wine beer liquor whatever it's fine
and the flip side of that is something
like say LSD something that's relatively
recently come into use and there's no
denying that you would need if you were
to take LSD you would need to be in a
safe place
would be important too to put yourself
in a position where you didn't hurt
anybody or hurt yourself but the
long-term there are not long-term
damaging effects of LSD the way that
there are for alcohol and so there's
this curious property of these drugs
that sometimes our perceptions of them
as a society are not quite the same as
the mechanisms of what they do to the
brain one one drug that's pretty
unambiguously bad is cocaine
methamphetamine a rule of thumb seems to
be that drugs that block dopamine uptake
have a lot of potential for addiction
and that's because addiction seems to
work through dopamine pathways in the
brain and they lead to dependencies that
can be very bad for you
so dopamine uptake blockers seem to be
bad for the brain
I think Goldman's ideas are very
interesting there's this old-school idea
that I that basically no one believes
anymore which is that intelligence is
just described by one factor or a
parameter that people used to call G for
general intelligence and that you either
had more of it or you had less of it and
and a certain element of that is still
true because there is a thing that you
can measure on tests that has to do with
fluid problem-solving that one that
people still call G and so that part's
true but I think one thing that's
interesting there with Goldman is the
idea that there are many mental
capacities that we have and they are to
a certain degree independent of one
another now it turns out they're less
independent than one might imagine it
turns out that on average people who are
better at say IQ tests on average tend
to be better in in social intelligence
now that might be hard to believe when
you go to university and quiz your
average mathematician you know not all
those people are all that socially
advanced but nonetheless there is a
positive relationship among these things
and they rely on slightly different
brain systems and so I think it's
possible for these capacities to be
somewhat independent of one another
creativity is a pretty general concept
and in order to reduce it into something
you can study you have to start thinking
about a problem that you can give
somebody in the laboratory and so for
instance there's a kind of problem
solving called divergent thinking
finding solutions that other people do
not find in the same problem okay so for
instance an example of creativity and an
animal might be if you have a crow so
imagine a box in which the box can
either be opened by flipping the lid
like this or by pulling on the lid like
this and what's what ethology have
discovered is that when you take a crow
most crows will learn how to open the
box like this and flip it like that okay
and occasionally a crow will have the
innovative thought of of pulling the box
the other way okay so that's an example
of divergent thinking that you can
identify in a crow and crows even have
social learning so for instance if one
crow sees another crow doing this it's
actually a raven if one raven sees
another raven do this then in fact it
can learn to do the the innov way
innovative way of solving the problem
right away and that's an example of
social learning and this is clearly
something that's very highly developed
in us right our cultural evolution
occurs far far faster than biological
evolution and so that kind of creativity
of tool-making is something that that
crows have a surprising amount of and
that we have and so one question is how
to study these things and and you have
to cook up tasks that are or more
germane so for instance that one example
is left-handers on average left-handers
seem to be more prone to divergent
thinking and creative ways of solving
problems at least in a laboratory
context and so that's one example of a
demographic that seems to have more of
this whatever it is
the popular belief about the left brain
and the right brain and people are
usually talking about the cerebral
cortex when they talk about these things
is that the left half of the brain is
rational and problem-solving and a none
creative and somehow the right brain is
creative it can help you draw better
right now the truth is more complicated
because in fact the hemispheres of the
brain because the hemispheres of the
brain are heavily interconnected by the
structure that's this basically this
dense band of fibers called the corpus
callosum and what seems to be really the
case is the left half of the brain is
important for for mathematical reasoning
for generating language but it's also a
storyteller so for instance in split
brain patients who have their corpus
callosum cut when you show a picture and
you play picture association with them
with the right half of the brain by
showing the left half of the world of
the person's world things and ask the
right half of the brain to do something
the right half the brain will happily
play picture association and then if you
ask the person well why did you make
that Association the left half of the
brain makes up a story so for instance
you could show the right half of the
brain a snow scene and a chicken claw
and the left brain sees the chicken claw
the right brain sees the snow scene and
then you said you have the right brain
well you know what goes with it and the
right brain will pick a shovel and then
the us left brain will why did you pick
a shovel and the left brain saw the
chicken claw and the left brain makes up
this crazy story the left brain will say
well you know the chicken lives in it
that's a claw it goes with a chicken the
chicken lives in a coop you need a
shovel to shovel out the chicken coop
it's this totally made-up story and so
it turns out that the left half of the
brain is perfectly capable of making up
stories and so that seems to be you know
that's sort of creative right so that's
not really that doesn't fit the
stereotype I think what's more the case
is that the right brain is important for
certain things so for instance the left
brain produces language the right brain
produces prosody which is the emotional
content of our language in many ways the
right brain on the other hand is quite
concrete and so I think the story is
more complicated and I think these
cultural ideas about left brain and
right brain have basically blown up all
out of proportion to to what scientists
have actually found about the left and
right brain
the question of nature and nurture is I
wouldn't call it settled but I would put
it like this we are all born with the
genetic inheritance and that genetic
inheritance sets boundaries on what we
might become it they guide us in the
sense of establishing about one-quarter
of the variation of what we might become
and that when it comes to intelligence
or personality it's some minority of
what we could become and then against
that genetic background then our
genetics and environment the experiences
that we have and the nutrition that we
get interact with one another and that
then shapes us over the course of
childhood and a lifetime and so most of
the variation is so most of the
variation turns out to be believed to be
environmentally induced or you know
based on experience and so it's some
interplay between the two that makes us
who we are
one thing that's interesting about child
development is that so much of it there
are so many changes that take place in
children's brains not only from birth to
the age of six is when people think of
brain change but also even through
childhood and into adolescence so one
thing that probably does not help is
passive experiences for the child and
the classic example of this is the
Mozart myth the idea that playing Mozart
or the classical music to a baby will
make the child smarter what seems to be
important is active engagement so for
instance learning to play a musical
instrument is associated with improved
spatial reasoning and that seems to be
something that really helps a lot
another thing that helps is talking to
children it's been shown that there's a
positive relationship between the number
of words a child hears per day and IQ
scores and this is true even when you
correct for socioeconomic status and so
just simply speaking to a child playing
with her talking with her that kind of
cognitive stimulation seems to have a
lasting positive effect on the child's
development and that's something that
that I think any parent can and should
do
well it's certainly the case that some
people who are called geniuses have the
ability to link unconnected ideas in
ways that other people can't see but one
important fact of that that's sort of I
would call that isn't so romantic is
this idea that Gladwell talks about
which is just the hard work of having
all that information on hand and
developing expertise through thousands
and thousands of hours of practice we
talked earlier about Google making us
dumber well look if Google removes the
need for us to have all that knowledge
on hand
and then that removes us from us the
ability to have these facts in our heads
on hand and so I think that this is one
area where we can think about something
that maybe gets lost a little bit right
geniuses are people who are in many
cases are people who have a lot of
information directly at their at their
beck and call and they think about it
and they start putting it together so
you know one component of genius is
sticking together things in unexpected
ways but another component is having
those things to stick together right and
I think that there's an element of truth
to this idea of thousands of hours of
practice making a creative scientist or
artist or writer or whatever it is that
we may care in ecology Gnaeus
so one thing I've experienced at
Princeton is that public spaces where my
colleagues and I are likely to cross
paths are excellent places to to share
ideas and to have discussions that rise
up spontaneously and at our campus the
genomics Institute is a newish building
that is has an atrium where we run
across one another and we have lunch or
coffee or what-have-you and that seems
to be a place where there's a lot of
ferment both socially and also
intellectually I repeatedly have
meetings there and so I think one
principle that comes up in modern design
for instance in scientific buildings is
creating spaces where people can cross
paths and I think that's an incredibly
important aspect of creating of spaces
where creativity is fostered and it's
some it's a real live version of
Facebook or Google and as much as people
like to talk about those social
networking sites personal networking
between live people face-to-face is
still far more effective than any kind
of online interaction
people have known that experience can
change the brain ever since it became
known that the brain was the seat of
consciousness thought and experience and
so I would say that for hundreds of
years has been known implicitly that the
brain must undergo change because of
course as the brain is the physical
object by which we generate our
consciousness and ourselves
then there must be some physical change
happening in the brain so in that sense
I think neuroplasticity has been known
implicitly
for centuries but I think it's really
been in the last few decades that has
become really appreciated exactly what
happens in the brain so about a little
over fifty years ago a Canadian
psychologist named Donald Hebb suggested
the specific idea that experience could
change the brain in ways that that
perhaps there'd be some pathway that
gets activated at an order of events
that gets turned on when we experience
something and that when we recall it we
are perhaps playing it back and have
suggested that and before him even
before him the pioneering psychologist
William James suggested it and you can
even find the suggestions of this the
the hints of this in writings of Thomas
Hobbes and even Aristotle so it's been
in the last 50 years or so that this
suggestion that's been around for
millennia has turned into a very
concrete suggestion about neural
pathways so that's neuroplasticity and
the adult brain then there's also
neuroplasticity in response to injury
and also during development and all
these things are facets that have been
studied facets of neuroscience that have
been studied over the last few decades
and it's becoming really appreciated how
much the brain can change
when challenged we can do more and
everyone knows this and when in the
absence of challenges we don't
necessarily reach our full potential now
I don't know that that necessarily means
that stress per se is good for the brain
what I mean by stress is very
specifically the secretion of steroid
hormones these hormones that turn up
when we are under some low-level
pressure when we're not allowed to sleep
or when we're under some kind of bodily
stress where we are put into some kind
of adverse condition for long periods of
time certainly pressure can make us
perform better but chronic stress has
been demonstrated to to slow down the
birth of new neurons to reduce the
plasticity of dendrites and so there are
physical consequences of chronic
exposure to stress hormones and and
those long-term effects of stress are
mostly unlikely to be very good for us
desk a bottle of pills that I picked him
in Chinatown once that are called brain
enhancer pills and I keep that sort of
thing around sometimes in my office is
basically a joke a lot of these
supplements have no demonstrated
positive effects on brain function and
that includes ginkgo biloba and includes
other supplements that you can take
that's one problem another problem that
of course is these supplements aren't
controlled for what's in them and so as
a result if you buy something like let's
say Saint John's wort there is
tremendous variation in what you're
getting when you buy those things so
even the claimed pharmacological agent
that's in them may be present in highly
variable quantities and something that
we would never accept in some
fda-approved drug the rule of thumb for
foods that may be good for the brain is
that things that are good for your heart
are good for your brain so it's again
this principle of good for your heart
good for your brain and examples of that
include
green leafy vegetables they include not
having too much in the way of saturated
fats because that improves your
circulation as you get older and your
brain lives off of oxygen in the blood
and so you need blood and so when your
heart's not getting the oxygen your
brains not getting the oxygen one
category of foods that seems to be
somewhat helpful is antioxidants so for
instance blueberries especially wild
blueberries have antioxidant properties
and they seem to have some kind of
protective effect on cognitive function
as we get older omega-3 fatty acids are
good for both the heart and for the
brain and in fact I myself take omega-3
fatty acids the old of all these things
you can take I mean just to put in
perspective the only things that I make
a point of eating are those and and
blueberries I like blueberries
therapy's well I'll be honest I don't
really know a lot about demonstrated
effects of these therapies like art
therapy and music therapy on the brain I
think one major mechanism that is worth
thinking about is the idea that these
therapies reduce stress one thing that
has been demonstrated is that stress
hormones are bad for the brain so for
instance sleep deprivation leads to the
secretion of stress hormones being in
danger I mean stress stress hormones are
stress hormones arose on the stress
response arose evolutionarily to be
something that works briefly if you're
in if there's danger or if there's
something that's caught your attention
and you need to get away from it the
idea is that you're certain systems in
your body shut down like your immune
response and the idea is that you got to
shut down the unnecessary things so you
can get it away from danger quickly so
that's the normal biological
evolutionary history of stress hormones
but now in modern times we have
situations in which stress is always
present and so one major way that these
therapies may work is by simply reducing
the secretion of stress hormones which
is good for the brain stress hormones
when chronically present can damage the
brain
it's not exactly it's not fully
understood what it is that exercise does
that's good for the brain empirical
observation is that the one of the best
things you can do to keep your brain
alive and healthy is fitness training
things that get your heart rate up the
kinds of things that you hear about
getting on the treadmill for three times
a week for at least 20 minutes in each
session that's a classic way of getting
fitness training and that's been
demonstrated to improve brain function
especially in older people the mechanism
is not known here are the two major
candidates one candidate is simply
improving blood flow to the brain and
again it's back to the heart brain
principle things are good for your heart
or good for the brain another major
mechanism that's been suggested is the
secretion of a signaling molecule whose
job it is to allow dendrites to grow and
to be plastic and this gets back to what
we were talking about before about
neuroplasticity this molecule is called
brain derived neurotrophic factor and if
you know what a neurotrophic factor you
know from the name what this does it's a
factor that's made in the brain that
causes neurons to grow it's a trophic
factor and that factor has been
demonstrated to improve plasticity and
dendrites and one hypothesis that people
are investigating is the idea that
exercise by triggering the secretion of
BDNF this neurotrophic factor may lead
to increased plasticity and improved
brain function
question because existing drugs like the
ones that you mentioned are all about
the plumbing and the mechanics of
especially in men of sexual performance
something that cuts to the heart of who
we are as loving or sexual beings is the
feeling of love and that's a whole other
category and major signaling molecules
in this category are molecules such as
oxytocin and arginine vasopressin
oxytocin and vasopressin are secreted
when we feel feelings of romantic love
they're also secreted when we feel
feelings of love towards a child so for
instance mothers when they hear their
baby cry will feel their milk drop and
the mechanism of that is the secretion
of these molecules to cause milk to be
secreted and so it's possible to to
reproduce feelings like that those same
signaling molecules are also important
in generating a feeling of trust so for
instance people who take oxytocin in the
form of a nasal spray exert more express
more trust when playing some negotiating
game with somebody and so now we're
talking about molecules that can affect
our emotional responses to other people
and that seems to cut somewhere to the
heart of what it means to be loving or
sexual
there's a subjective report that that
meditators report right feelings of
peace feelings in being able to focus
there are many versions of meditation
and the version of meditation people
practice leads to different effects so
for instance Buddhists report a
particular state of object less
compassion so feeling compassion without
any specific object without a person as
the target one thing that's been
observed experimentally is that when you
put people into a brain scanner and look
to see what happens in their brains it's
possible to measure very large
electrical oscillations and the brains
of say Carmelite nuns experiencing
mystical union with God or experienced
Buddhist practitioners entering this
object list compassion state and what's
observed is that you can see these
oscillations which basically are the
result of neurons being active in sync
with one another and at being active
more or less in cycle with one another
Buddhist monks can achieve an
oscillation of that and what's called
the gamma frequency band that's only
found in non expert meditators when
they're having seizures okay so these
people can do something extreme with
their brains and I'm not sure that it
reveals anything about the nature of
reaching enlightenment or the benefits
of meditation but I think the one thing
that's very interesting about it is
finding a neural signature that shows
exactly which parts of the brain may be
trained when people learn to be very
good at these things and I think that
scientifically that's a rich source of
questions for investigation
our brains abilities to think about and
model the world or double-edged more
than any other animal we have the
capability it seems to look into the
future and to make plans for the future
and that's basically cuz we've got those
tremendous cortex especially a
prefrontal cortex that allows us to make
these plans for the future but at the
same time we are also limited we are
remarkably bad at seeing the downstream
effects of what our acts will lead to
five years or ten years down the road
we're just not very good at that and so
it's difficult to judge whether
something some life decision you make
today will make you happy a few years
down the road one way to get around that
is to simply find someone who was faced
with the same decision a few years down
the road a few years in the past and ask
them well how did you feel after making
that decision and so one thing you can
do is to find people who faced with the
same challenge and the make and report
accurately how it made them happy or
unhappy one thing about happiness that's
funny is that we are remarkably
resilient in adapting to events so you
might imagine that that's something like
losing a limb would really affect what's
happiness but studies have shown that
losing a limb causes it you know you're
less happy when you lose on them but
after a few years you adapt out and it's
as if almost as if you had not lost the
limb in terms of your happiness
something's never adapt out so examples
of things that never adapt out are
losing a loved one if you lose your life
partner that makes you less happy and
that doesn't go away
another thing that reduces your
happiness in the long term and never
goes away is something that's less
serious and it's commuting so it turns
out that having a long commute makes you
slightly less happy and you never get
used to it
human beings are remarkably adaptable
think of us as having come out of Africa
from this little Valley and then
dispersing throughout the world and
living in places like Finland and and
you know in Indonesia and in the United
States and all over the world
it's amazing how adaptable human beings
are and so one thing that seems to be a
very striking characteristic of humans
including their brains is the
adaptability both by being clever and
making tools and shaping our
environments to be more satisfactory to
us and also adaptability and how
we react to our environments and so one
thing that seems to be a hallmark of our
species is how good we are at that and
if you compare that with any other
species we seem to be very very good
our only close competitors might be
cockroaches
autism research autism has been very
much in the news lately and it's pretty
much everywhere you look it's been a
really remarkable thing to watch just as
a phenomenon of watching people become
very interested in it my younger sister
is autistic and when I was a child the
only thing I knew about autism was the
fact that Karen was autistic now it
seems to be in the news everywhere
what's known about autism the number one
thing that's known about autism is that
it seems to be largely genetically
determined
if one identical twin is autistic then
the odds of the other twin having some
kind of autism spectrum disorder is
between 50 and 80 percent and that's
just a tremendous probability and that's
not the case for non identical twins for
fraternal twins and so that's a major
piece of evidence that autism is largely
genetic and one big story in the last
five years has been the identification
of genes that that increase the risk of
autism and it's not one gene it seems to
be some more complex polygenic disorder
where you get dealt a bunch of genes
from from your mother and your your
father from your father and if you draw
the wrong combination of genes say
between two and ten genes then that
increases the risk of being autistic so
that's the main thing that's known as
far as as far as the the later
development of it people are starting to
look at structural differences between
the brains of autistic people and what
are called neurotypical people and those
are changes that take place in the
neocortex which is the largest part of
our brain and also in the cerebellum
which people used to think of as being a
sensory or motor structure but seems to
be perhaps important also for for more
advanced cognitive tasks and so the
cerebellum as has been fingered in the
last few years as far as treatments for
autism right now the one kind of
treatment that seems to be somewhat
helpful is behavioral therapy especially
when children are diagnosed and
identified as needing the help young and
so that is interesting because it's the
one way that seems to possibly help kids
who have autism and it may be part of
why diagnosis rates have gone up because
it's recognized that those therapies can
help kids and so people are motivated to
identify these problems and their kids
when they're young because that's when
it's possible to maybe catch these
things and
help these kids integrate better into
the rest of society
one characteristic of autism therapy in
the last few years has been basically
taking autistic kids and seeing what can
be done to help them and I think that's
sort of I wouldn't call it palliative
but it's it's in the category of helping
kids who are already diagnosed with
autism who have already been through a
lot of the developmental stages that
lead to autism and it's some and in some
sense the horse is out of the barn and
then it's a question of what you can do
to help these kids - to bring to them
the kind of social skills that would
help them work much better in society I
think treatment is a ways away it's um
it's not in the next five years or even
next ten years but I think that
understanding the mechanisms in
development that lead to autism could
eventually lead to some kind of therapy
that could perhaps nip autism in the bud
when kids are you know when their brains
are making these developmental choices
early in life so I think it's a ways off
but I think the research starts pointing
towards better therapies
there are cases of people who can
perform astounding mathematical feats
with their brains and and to my
knowledge it is not well understood
exactly what it's doing there one way to
think about it is that our brains are
kind of sloppy we have these shortcuts
and tricks that our brains use honed
over millions of years of evolution to
come up with quantitative intuitions
about the world and there's something
that's possible that most of us don't
tap and what's interesting is the idea
that these people use other algorithms
entirely that somehow they've run across
to perform their mathematical feats I
think it's not well understood and I'm
not sure that that we're in a position
right now to understand how they do that
well what start had something going
right he didn't he right - uncle - uncle
little star when he was six you know I
look I mean no offense to most of the
world's six-year-olds but you know most
six-year-olds aren't writing tunes that
survived across the ages so clearly
Mozart had something going in the case
of Einstein Einstein was a very very
smart man who in his 20s made a series
of discoveries in rapid succession that
completely upended our understanding of
the world but one thing he had as well
was he was thinking very hard about
these problems he had a patent clerk job
that allowed him to think hard about
physical problems you know kind of on
the side and so he was given the
opportunity to to daydream a little bit
on the job and that was that was pretty
valuable
I've never been to a brain gym and I
think it would be a fun experience so
brain gyms off obviously play on a fear
that by not being mentally engaged we
will somehow you know it's a user to
lose it kind of thing and there is a
grain of truth to this which is that one
of the things that you can do to keep
your brain happy and functioning well as
you get older is to have a mentally
engaged lifestyle so the number one
correlative retained cognitive function
as people get older is educational
status and it's not clear whether that's
because being educated gives you the
tools to lead a more engaged life or
whether or maybe if you're a more
intellectually engaged engaged person
you might be the kind of person who
would go to college and graduate school
so it's not you know it's a chicken-egg
problem but in either case that's the
number one correlate in general
individual tasks that you learn when you
play brain games and you go to brain
gyms tend to only increase your capacity
at that particular task or tasks as that
type and they tend to lead to small
benefits and so I think a lot of these
exercises don't lead to large benefits
now it could be that doing a lot of
these different things is something like
a full body workout then it could be
that there's some moderate benefit but I
think the people who go to those should
really remember not only the
intellectual principle right a sound
mind but also the sound body principle
and so I think any such gym should
include what we talked about earlier
fitness training
so there are different kinds of
cognitive and memory loss that occur
with aging certain kinds of memory loss
are such as forgetting where your car
keys are are part of the normal process
of getting older and in fact memory
Peaks surprisingly early at the age of
30 and then declines gradually with time
so forgetting where your keys are is not
a cause of particular concern and then
there's dementia which is forgetting say
that you you know like the the old saw
goes that if you forget where your
glasses are that's normal memory loss if
you forget the fact that you wear
glasses
that's dementia and so there are
different degrees of this so just normal
memory loss is not a cause of concern
it's not well understood exactly what
physically underlies this
although plausible candidates are loss
of the brain's ability to form new
connections or to easily modulate the
weight of the connections between nerve
cells those are called synaptic weights
and so those would be candidates for why
the brain seems to be less plastic in
certain ways as we get older but it's
not super well understood now there's
another category of memory loss this
severe decline in the form of dementia
and the thing that's understood there is
that you can look in the brains of
people who after death are diagnosed as
having Alzheimer's disease and they have
plaques and tangles that appear to be
either the causes of cell death or
perhaps the residue the aftermath of
cell death and these plaques and tangles
seem to be at the root of certain kinds
of of cognitive loss and that's
something that some that's studied now
and is a pretty active area of research
and the current goal is to try to find
ways to stave off those cognitive losses
by even a few years because as we live
longer having a few years becomes very
important
there are two kinds of ways that
neuroscience may be transforming one
that's internal to the field another
that perhaps links to the rest of
society so let's start with
neuroscientists one thing that
neuroscientists are very interested in
right now is understanding how how
genetics and development can lead to the
wiring of a brain and one thing that's
become very big in the last few years is
the idea that we may start having enough
technology to be able to completely map
out a circuit of a fairly advanced piece
of tissue like part of our brains or
part of the brain of a mouse and
technologies are being developed to
basically give us the circuit diagram so
everyone's heard of the human genome
project in which you sequence the entire
genome of say a human being there's
something that is jokingly called the
human brain ohm project which is to come
up with something that analogous in
terms of mapping out the brains both are
mapping out human brains both over long
distances and also in detail and I think
that technology has the potential to be
transformative to how neuroscientists
think about the problems that they're
working on now there's another aspect of
that question which is how neuroscience
is going to transform or interact with
the rest of society and there's two ways
that that can happen one way is I think
the medical way which we all are
thinking about you asked me before about
Alzheimer's disease as we start
beginning to understand the brain as a
biological organ we can start addressing
neurological diseases like like autism
schizophrenia Parkinson's and I think
that's something where they're gonna be
huge advances and then there's this
other kind of thing that's not medical
and let's call it philosophical the idea
that our brains underlie a wide variety
of human experiences so for instance
criminality what does it mean to be
criminally culpable economic behavior
what is it that causes an economic
bubble why do bubbles form and why do
they burst what is it that makes us fall
in love what is it that makes us form
friendships why do we declare war on
people we've never met and all of these
things are aspects of human experience
and I guess what I'm claiming here is
that as neuroscience advances we're
gonna start understanding all of these
things in terms of brain mechanisms and
I think that all these things are old
things
have been with us for from time
immemorial but I think that as
neuroscience advances they're all going
to look a little bit different
if people are interested in the brain I
mean at a very basic level I think our
book welcome to your brain is something
that's fairly introductory for people
who have no knowledge at all I think
that one thing that people can read if
they want to keep up with current
discoveries that's always fun to read is
the magazine Scientific American mind I
know that I'm always learning new things
from that it ranges from discoveries
that my colleagues are making about
hates say how glial cells work or how
neuroplasticity may work to to things
that are very much concerns in everyday
life like why is it that we are unable
to imagine death or why do we
procrastinate and I find that that
magazine is a great resource for people
at all levels both introductory and also
very expert
I don't know the answer to the question
is Google making us stupid that's a
funny one I have to admit that I'm kind
of stodgy I am a big fan of learning
factual knowledge and having those facts
at the ready and I think that's
important and one thing I very much
noticed is that this is something that
is less emphasized in my students and
and I think that's going to continue in
the future
one thing that getting back to the cost
of concept of fluid intelligence and G
is that modern society for the last
hundred years has increasingly rewarded
reasoning skills and the manipulation of
knowledge as opposed to the collection
of knowledge and I think that Facebook
and Google or just modern the most
recent manifestations of that increasing
trend my own view is that I think
there's a lot of value in the learning
of factual knowledge and I think that
that is something that's being lost but
the thing that's gained is that at the
press of a key you can get facts and
start to manipulate them and turn them
to something new and so I think there's
a large gain and I don't know how to
trade off those those two things
video games have the potential for
improving cognitive function um there's
a researcher
Daphne bevel here who is very interested
in the effects of video games so for
instance one kind of thing that seems to
occur is that video games improve
hand-eye coordination and that's a
fairly obvious thing depending on the
type of video game say for instance if
it's a complex game like Sim City that
can lead to improvements in task
switching and so it seems likely
although I don't think it's been exactly
demonstrated it seems highly likely that
video games might improve multitasking
abilities there are limits to
multitasking basically multitasking in
most cases leads to decreased
performance in both tasks but at the
same time it's a thing that is
potentially trainable by video games
I think that what kurtzweil does is take
existing discoveries whether it be in
computer science or in neuroscience and
extrapolates to them to the maximum so
if you look in the singularity is near
he does a very good job of describing
current neuro scientific discoveries by
my friends and colleagues and and
describing what's been what's been done
and then he takes those and drives them
up to the maximum possible
interpretation and so you know maybe we
can observe a single synaptic connection
being formed or breaking that's where
the state of the art is but that doesn't
mean that we can map an entire brain or
copy a brain that would be a massive
technological challenge so that's one
just an example of being a little bit
too optimistic another practical problem
is that computational power is
increasing tremendously and he calls
upon that idea but the fact of the
matter is that is that energetic
efficiency isn't quite increasing enough
to keep pace and so for instance he'd
likes to cite the year 2020 as a time
when we could have something about the
size of a brain that would compute as
well as the brain does but it looks to
me like looking at those trends that the
amount of power that such a thing would
consume would be about as much power as
is consumed by all of Washington DC so
there's a practical issue there now if
brain function is ever replicated in any
meaningful way it's probably going to
rely heavily on the idea that we're
gonna start understanding the heuristics
and the non algorithmic principles
underlying how brains work so looking at
real brains for instance looking at how
we use emotions to guide decisions or
looking at the shortcuts that are that
actual brains use to to make decisions
and to assign value to things those
things are very much the meat and
potatoes of current neuroscience and
where neuroscience is headed and so it's
possible to imagine using those
principles to make better computing
devices but I think that replacing our
brains by the year 2020 well let's just
say I would be willing to place a very
large wager against that